[Music]
what's up guys I'm Katie brows and we're
running down the best dressed celebs of
the week check out Queen B at the title
like Brooklyn charity concert on Tuesday
the emerald green gown is custom Walter
Mendez all those Lorraine Schwartz a no
fear in jewels they're worth more than
five million dollars it was so much fun
I bet it was Beyonce that
crystal-covered money roll clutch by
Alexander Wang and Judith Leiber goes
for about $5,000 and check out her 695
dollar Christian Louboutin heels max
Margo Ravi a tells women in Hollywood
celebration even Jennifer Lawrence took
notice Margot Robbie is so pretty that I
think I should go home
skin tight black dress is Calvin Klein
by appointment and apparently priceless
because there was made just for Margo
but her jeweled ankle strap heels also
Calvin Klein are worth a whopping one
thousand four hundred and ninety five
dollars I have something to say tonight
and and I think I think a lot of women
do also want to have something to say
and stand up for our place in the
industry
zendaya went fistic ated and she can
head to toe H&M on Wednesday nights at
the launch party for the brand-new
collab with airs M photographer is
really great call my English and the
looks well break the bank I'd love to be
a part of that sweater and $99 the
floral skirts 199 dollars and the
earrings at 39 you know I know is really
good finally Blake Lively was a
bombshell and NYC on Monday opting for
menswear by Ralph Lauren I just I like
clothes I like you know I like mixing
singing that coat three thousand four
hundred and ninety bucks so blazer 1990
dollars the pants just shy of a thousand
bucks and get this the alligator satchel
from the fall 2017 Michael Kors
collection
retails for 18
thousand dollars well I'm really lucky
to have access to really great designers